es soll herr holetschek idee von jens
spahn für diejenigen die in quarantäne
sind nicht mehr lohnfortzahlung geben
also es soll in der quarantänezeit der
lohn abgezogen werden oder für die zeit
sagen sie das ist richtig oder sagen sie
einzelne länder haben das übrigens schon
sofort übernommen oder sagen sie es ist
nicht schlau den leuten jetzt
hinterrücks ein bisschen druck zu machen
ich glaube darum geht es nicht dieses
thema ist ja im paragraf 56 das
infektionsschutzgesetz schon seit märz
2020 drin da heißt es dann wenn ich eine
impfung die mir zumutbar ist nicht mache
und deswegen in quarantäne kommt dann
fällt irgendwann die verdienstausfalls
entschädigung weg und es ist eine
konsequenz wenn die impfung zumutbar ist
und nicht gesundheitliche gründe dagegen
sprechen dann gibt es irgendwann auch
kein grund mehr dass diese
verdienstausfalls entschädigung
letztlich vom steuerzahler wieder
gezahlt wird in bayern waren es bis
jetzt 83 millionen das hat aus meiner
sicht auch nichts mit druck zu tun
sondern ist eine konsequenz wie auch
dass irgendwann die tests nicht mehr
kostenlos sind sondern wir müssen
einfach auch konsequent sein indem wir
die dinge tun und ich glaube das ist
richtig wir werden das jetzt auf der
gesundheitsministerin und
ministerkonferenz auch noch mal
besprechen gemeinsam einige länder sind
schon vorangegangen der lauterbacher
dells nicht für gut ich habe euch nicht
zersetzen auch am sensibelsten an
nämlich am geld es geht nicht um an
drogen ist bei einer besonders eins wenn
ich eine impfung die zumutbar ist
unmöglich und kein gesundheitlicher
grund dagegen spricht nicht mache dann
darf das nicht mehr zu lasten der
gesellschaft
sie müssen doch die auswirkungen sehen
die eine solche wenn ich ein spanisch
hat ihn gestern wirklich oft gesehen
immer wieder das gleiche sagen was hat
das für auswirkungen auf personen die
sich bislang nicht haben impfen lassen
glauben sie das führt dazu tatsächlich
dass sie sich eher impfen lassen was ja
das ziel davon sein sollte ich glaube es
sind verschiedene tatbestände an die wir
anknüpfen einmal müssen wir natürlich
positiv diese motivation bringen dass
ich nicht ins glas wir dürfen aber nicht
vergessen dass eben die die sich impfen
lassen dass auch bewusst tun und ich
nicht den anderen die es einfach nicht
wollen oder die trittbrettfahrer sind
und sagen ich warte mal bis alle anderen
sich haben impfen lassen dann einfach
einen tatbestand einräumen der nicht
möglich ist ja das hat eine gefahr das
problem ist doch so wenn wir dies im
gesetz steht es ist ja vielleicht auch
noch nicht jeder dann sind wir das
gesetz
könnten wir ja aussetzen
könnten es aus wenn wir wollten könnten
wir es aus als hätten die frage warum
hat beantworten aber ich würde nur sagen
die frage ist nicht beantwortet indem
ich sage das steht im gesetz was können
wir aus setzte ein grund es nichts zu
machen liegt darin was wird denn
passieren bei denjenigen die glauben
dass sie sich infiziert haben na ja die
werden sich gar nicht erst testen lassen
und also
fertig ist die laube ich sagen dann
einfach in japan erkältung und warum
soll und dass das so ist dann läuft dann
läuft uns die infektionswelle weg denn
wenn also die leute die jetzt nicht
gefährden wollen wenn ich die versuche
auf diese art unter druck zu setzen
das ist zu leicht aushebeln baut die
tests kommt das nicht noch dazu also
warum soll jemand der sich nicht impfen
lassen die dann auch noch bereits sein
geld für so eine testphase zu videos aus
der eigenen tasche den test um danach
keine lohnfortzahlung surfen das wird
nicht stattfinden natürlich das heißt
die menschen werden verleugnen dass sie
sich infiziert haben wenn die werden die
werden merken dass sie eine kette was
oft passiert es wird der kluge
bestätigen wollen die reihe unterwegs
der laie unterschätzt wenn er seine
erkältung hat wenn das cofidis du denkst
es geht wieder weg wenn die leute ein
paar tage sagen mal wirklich gestellt
haben mittleres lebens mittleres
lebensalter und haben ein risikofaktor
die kommen schwer krank auf die
intensivstation gekommen sozusagen die
sich am zweiten tag sind die schon auf
der intel sich dazu weiter aus also
sagen wir weg geschoben haben sie kommen
zu spät rein und daher aus meiner sicht
also sollten wir dann ehrlicher sein und
sagen wir praktizieren zweig das ist gut
begründbar weil damit schütze ich die
unten die ungeimpften untereinander und
auch die geimpften also klare aber nicht
ganz so populärer linie aber bei der
lohnfortzahlung da würde ich nicht an
sind sie nicht dabei und die
auskunftspflicht
in bezug auf den arbeitgeber sagen sie
die sollte stattfinden oder sie sollte
nur in einzelnen bereichen start der
meinung von herrn palma was nicht so
häufig vorkommt oder was zunehmend ist
sofort fest kommt sie hat aber da bin
ich der meinung von die berufe wo quasi
also womit sich jemand jemandem
anvertraut da kann ich erwarten dass der
also geimpft ist die menschen sind also
da ausgeliefert sind demjenigen der
behandelt oder betreut oder pflegt oder
zieht uns so da muss ich in diese
berufung durch reingehen aber bei den
anderen beruf würde ich das nicht machen
freiheit ihrer schönheit den kopf nein
nein nicht dazu nochmal zu der frage
weil mich das wirklich umtreibt weil es
ja eine strafe ist oder der maßnahme die
sich auch gegen eine gruppe nämlich jene
der erwerbstätigen richtet also eine
partikulare maßnahme warum macht man da
nicht etwas wenn man schon so bestraft
welches alle gruppen gleichermaßen nicht
nur die erwerbstätigen im begriff strafe
nicht richtig um ihr lieber sein herz
jeder einen anspruch den ich habe auf
eine verdienstausfalls entschädigung und
den verwirkliche ich indem ich mir eine
zumutbare maßnahmen dazu und das ist die
impfung und der staat kann in der stelle
aus meiner sicht dabei straftat sondern
er sagt du könntest dich doch impfen
lassen das ist dir zumutbar bund der
steuerzahler übernimmt dann eben nicht
mehr diesen verdienstausfall meter hohes
und gehen auf die frage warum es nur die
erwerbstätigen mit den beamten holten
wir fragen einfach mal boris palmer
entwickeln wie würden sie entscheiden
wird zu viel druck ausgeübt oft die
menschen die sich noch nicht dazu
entschieden haben sich impfen zu lassen
herr palmer würden sie sagen dann muss
uns etwas besseres einfallen als jetzt
ausgerechnet zwei wochen quarantänezeit
vom lohn abziehen
also ich bin wie fast immer der meinung
von frau allmendinger und immer häufiger
der meinung von herrn lauterbach in der
tat konzerthaus an was gehabt in der tat
kommt darauf an was man erreichen möchte
wenn es sozusagen um eine art von
gerechtigkeit geht manchmal wird es ja
als gerecht dargestellt dass derjenige
der die impfung verweigert dann halt die
folgen es soll finanzieller art er soll
den test bezahlen der soll dann der eine
lohnfortzahlung nicht mehr haben und so
weiter dann mag das an bestimmten
bedürfnis entsprechen die sich bei
vielen menschen treffen in der politik
erstaunlich oft höre dass sozial
gerechtes so zu machen wenn man das ziel
hat die pandemien griff zu bekommen hat
avatar lauterbach recht es ist
kontraproduktiv es verstärkt bei dem die
sich nicht impfen lassen wollen den
widerstand das ist ein ganz starker
widerstand der verstärkt wird erst recht
nicht und es reduziert die
wahrscheinlichkeit die infektionen zu
entdecken und damit werden sie häufiger
weitergegeben das gilt ganz besonders
für die kostenlosen test die unsere
fabelhafte notärztin lisa federle in
tübingen erfunden hat er war wirklich
toll wenn ich das aufgreifen da freuen
klar und wir wollen das auch
weitermachen weil wir glauben dass sogar
geimpfte wenn sie eine hochzeit machen
gut daran tun vorher mal zu gucken ob da
eine infektion weitergereicht wird und
insbesondere die nicht geimpften deshalb
weiter gibt dass die sich wie die sich
oft testen lassen kostenlos dass die der
gesellschaft damit einen dienst tun und
das jetzt zu sagen das ist zu teuer das
können wir uns nicht leisten und die
sollen das selber bezahlen das ist
sparen an der falschen stelle ich bin
als schwabe immer vor sparen aber nicht
wenn ich nachher weniger geld in der
tasche haben als vorher durch das sparen
und das ist ja der fall ist kostet uns
effektiv sehr viel mehr schneiden und zu
zeigen vielleicht würde ich davon
abraten dieses bedürfnis die
impfverweigerer jetzt endlich zur kasse
zu bitten auszuleben das hilft uns
wirklich nicht wir müssen erkennen die
gruppe der impfverweigerer ist nicht so
groß also diese 16 millionen die
momentan nicht geimpft sind das sind
nicht alles in farbe hat die große masse
ist träge das sind im zauberer und
zögerer und die erreicht man natürlich
schon durch zweig aber auch durch solche
finanziellen sanktionen
das muss uns klar sein also die wirklich
harten im verweigerer das ist wo man die
minderheit und die anderen müssen wir
erreichen und die müssen wir erreichen
und dann würden sie auch sagen muss man
jetzt nicht unbedingt die das
bonusprogramm irgendwie erfinden sondern
auch wenn er sich aus sagen es ist ich
kenne die selbstverantwortung als
privatperson kann nicht sprechen wenn
ich höre dass 500 millionen euro da
eine lohnfortzahlung
zeitung herausgegeben wurden in
bundesländern dann frage ich mich schon
ob das gerechtfertigt ist und ich glaube
schon dass so solche maßnahmen zu mehr
bereitschaft ist im zauberer gruppe
führen wir im pflicht ist noch so ein
stichwort das auch diskutiert wird und
wir hier unbedingt diskutieren sollten
vielleicht also erstmal die frage nach
tübingen herr palmer in pflichten für
einzelne berufszweige und berufsgruppen
das machen andere länder ja sehr sehr
wohl und mit auch drakonischen maßnahmen
wer das nicht macht wird entlassen in
italien glaube ich und in großbritannien
gibt es auch diesbezüglich eben in
einzelnen wichtigen branchen eine hartes
regime da haben sie schon gesagt dass
sie das richtig und wichtig finden und
was ist mit denjenigen die es nicht
machen
wenn wir eine impfpflicht für solche
berufsgruppe auflegen die das dann nicht
tun
na gut man kann man arbeitskräfte ich
eingreifen zuerst mal müssen die dann
wenn sie zu hause bleiben weil sie nicht
zur arbeit gehen können neben ihren
urlaub einsetzen und dann stellt man sie
unbezahlt frei und wenn es dann immer
noch nicht greift dann ist im
zweifelsfall auch mit abmahnungen und
entlassungen im notfall arbeitsrechtlich
alles möglich das würde ich jetzt ungern
ausprobieren aber tatsächlich ist es
wenn er im pflicht kommt dann die
logische konsequenz war es kann nicht
sein dass man sich nicht impfen lässt
dann nicht zur arbeit kommt und dann
sozusagen wollen das gehalt bezieht als
wäre nichts das ist dann schon
unvermeidlich ich hoffe dass es nicht
sofort nötig ist aber für die genannten
berufsgruppen erwarte ich eigentlich
auch das der einzig da ist dass man den
schutz der menschen die einem an
befohlen sind dass man dem auch soweit
entspricht dass man für die nicht selber
zu gefahr werden wenn man sich nicht
haben wir schon gesagt allgemeine
impfpflicht wäre noch mal eine frage
auch das ist ja durchaus zu erwägen und
zu diskutieren eine allgemeine
impfpflicht kluge würde ihnen schon eine
menge sorgen nehmen das stimmt es würde
eine überlastung des gesundheitssystems
und auch der wirtschaft sicherlich
vermeiden aber es wird die gesellschaft
sehr spalten denke ich werde das auch
diskutiert die meisten ärzte wehren er
für eine impfpflicht denke ich schon
aber allein im pflegebereich wird das
ein riesiges problem wir wissen dass die
bei den pflegekräften zum beispiel nicht
100 prozent geimpft sind wenn wir die
alle nach hause schicken und seien es
nur zehn prozent die nicht geimpft sind
ein riesenproblem wir haben sowieso eine
flucht aus der intensivpflege eine
flucht aus der altenpflege und wenn wir
da jetzt noch mitarbeiterinnen verlieren
weil sie nicht geimpft sind die werden
ja bei uns regelmäßig getestet also das
haben wir unter kontrolle dann ist das
ein problem deswegen hat die impfpflicht
lage deutlich sein und das ist
juristisch sicherlich auch heikel und
schüttelt hier die rechte seite des
tisches auch den kopf dann ist es
vielleicht wichtig mal über 2g zu reden
das sind die genesenen und die geimpften
das ist hier schon ein paar mal gefallen
am tisch in bezug auf die
digitalisierung mühen wir uns ja um 5 g
um dieses zweig gibt es nun möglich
einen ausserordentlichen streit
exklusiver zugang nur für geimpfte und
genesene nicht für getestete um zweig
ist ein streit entbrannt
für die einen ist es die
wiederherstellung der grundrechte wir
wollen eine zusätzliche option für
diejenigen die geimpft und genesen sind
da kann man dann auf andere vorgaben die
bei 3g gelten verzichten 2gb so oder so
auf einem bestimmten zeitpunkt kommen
und mir wäre es lieber würden jetzt
ehrlich darüber reden als es zu vertagen
bis nach der bundestagswahl
für andere ist es druck durch
diskriminierung auf ungeimpfte
ich finde am ende freiheitsrechte müssen
für alle gelten wenn man keine
impfpflicht will auch wissenschaftlich
bleibt zweig umstritten denn das ist ja
suggeriert dass von einem getesteten
mehr gefahr ausgehen würde ein höheres
risiko ausgehen würde als von einem
geimpften oder genesenen und das ist
wissenschaftlich nicht belegt und man
könnte genauso auch andersherum
argumentieren dass ein getesteter
wahrscheinlich eine niedrigere
wahrscheinlichkeit hat das virus in sich
zu tragen und das virus weiter zu geben
als eingeimpft
wir müssen schon wieder ordnen wir
fangen linksaußen nur geografisch bei
hologic an es wird auf zweig
hinauslaufen sagt markus söder warum
machen wir es dann nicht also ich denke
wir müssen mal die konsequenzen sehen
wenn wir jetzt hören dass die
gesundheitssysteme überlastet werden
durch die ungeimpften dann werden wir
irgendwann auch überlegen müssen welche
maßnahmen haben wir wenn wir an die rote
ampel kommen und das sind maßnahmen die
sich dann gegen die ungeimpften auch mit
richten werden im rahmen der kontakt
beschränkungen und einschränkungen und
insofern ist eine logische konsequenz
irgendwann dieses zweig ich glaube aber
dass wir jetzt noch in einem status sind
wo wir 3g haben dass wir den weg jetzt
auch konsequent noch gehen und dass wir
da jetzt keine drohszenarien aufbauen
sondern sagen es ist für jeden
nachvollziehbar irgendwann kommt der
punkt wo einfach das thema der
ungeimpften auch in den krankenhäusern
noch mehr landet und deswegen müssen wir
dann schützen und kontakt beschränkungen
in diesem bereich treffen sind sie herr
kluge führt zweig oder für 3g ist um
herrn strikt aufzunehmen ist ein
aktueller test sein aktueller frischer
tests gleichwertig mit einer impfung
weil sie nach weist oder er nachweist
dass derjenige eben nicht infiziert nein
das denke ich nicht wir haben den test
sehr verschiedene qualitätsstufen wir
haben die anti gen test sie haben zwei
große probleme die durchführung ist sehr
unterschiedlich abhängig vom anwender
und die anti geht es sind halt
von der sensitivität und spezifität sehr
sehr unterschiedlich und das wissen auch
dass die häufig falsch positiv sind aber
auch verschwägert tief trotzdem
wurde an das zeichnen sie an aber es
gibt immer wieder probleme und die pcs
sind deutlich besser werden aber nur
selten durchgeführt und sofern denki ist
bei einem geimpften das risiko dass der
von dem eine gefahr ausgeht deutlich
geringer ja und insofern ist in hamburg
jahr zweig etabliert und das hat sich
meines erachtens bewährt und es wird
auch darauf hinauslaufen dass läge schon
und es wird darauf hinauslaufen sagen
sie das auch boris palmer besagen sie
auch das wird auf zweig hinauslaufen
oder sagen sie so sehr erfahren
natürlich auch mit den tests das haben
sie schon erwähnt dass sie an dem testen
nicht nur festhalten wollen sondern dass
es auch ein zeichen von
freiheit ist die getesteten genauso zu
behandeln wie die genesenen und die
kämpften
wir müssen da wirklich aufpassen dass
diese balance zwischen freiheit und
gesundheitsschutz dass die nicht gibt
und das sehe ich schon gefahren bei 2
gibt jedenfalls dann wenn man das
voreilig ausruft dass es darauf
hinausläuft meiner auffassung nach ist
es eine notmaßnahme falls die
gesundheitssysteme wieder im kritischen
bereich kommen das ist keineswegs sicher
das kann sein aber die aktuelle welle
hat jetzt wieder mehr wert von 1 und
möglicherweise läuft sie auch wieder
zurück wissen wir nicht aber im moment
steigen die zahlen jetzt nicht mehr an
können so 3g überprüfen also kann der
bürgermeister organisieren der
oberbürgermeister der stadt organisieren
das eben auch in den namen
verkehrsmitteln grundsätzlich überprüft
wird getestet wird ob
die menschen eben einen gültigen test
haben
praktisch können wir den kommunen alles
wenn man uns dazu die nötigen
finanzmittel und die rechtlichen
instrumente in die hand gibt es können
wir wenn wir das wollen derzeit ist es
rechtlich nicht möglich aber
administrativ kriegen wir das im griff
ich will auch noch einen punkt machen
ich glaube wir sollten jetzt nicht
voreilig sagen es läuft auch zweig
hinaus weil die freiheits eingriffe die
das bedeutend sind sehr massiv ich halte
die für hochproblematisch und das
einzige was als rechtfertigung dienen
kann ist in deutschland im
gesundheitssystem alles andere ist mein
hunger in hamburg jetzt in den klubs
natürlich nicht also warum das hat
schenker denken sie
den klubs finden ist völlig richtig da
ist zwar in ordnung dessen so hoch
intensiver kontakt der da irgend auf der
tanzfläche stattfindet das 2g ist und da
ist ja die alternative lockdown weil es
war ja anderthalb jahre verboten das
finde ich in ordnung aber wenn wir jetzt
zwei gehen immer größer und bereichen
der gesellschaft bekämen womöglich am
ende in der kultur beim einkaufen oder
ähnliches dann würde ich sagen das geht
entschieden zu weit diese freiheits
eingriffe können jetzt sicher nicht
einfach mal so angekündigt werden dass
es darauf hinausläuft dass hielt ich
wirklich für eine dramatische bedrohung
auch der verfassungsmäßig garantierten
grundrechte es ist interessant hält
lauterbach was sagen sie formulieren sie
auch es wird auf zweig hinauslaufen wenn
sich die lage weiter verschlechtert oder
sagen sie zweig ist am ende
besser ich würde sagen dass zweig am
ende besser ist daher stehe ich also
peter tschentscher und auch markus söder
dazu und ich habe auch herrn kluge zu
dass es also nicht nachvollziehbar ist
was er strickt gesagt hat dass also ein
getesteter möglicherweise mit einem
antigen testet es dass der also sicherer
negativ ist aus als jemand der geimpft
ist das darf man auch so nicht stehen
lassen weil was macht den eindruck als
wenn die geimpften tatsächlich eine
gefahr noch immer darstellen würden wir
wissen dass wenn eine durchbruch
infektion kommt an geimpft a infiziert
sich dass er dann in der regel sehr viel
weniger ansteckend ist für andere als
jemand der sich infiziert hat und
umkämpft war somit der geimpfte ist
besser geschützt vor longo fit vor einem
schweren verlauf und er ist weniger
gefährlich vertreter das muss ganz ganz
klar eine impfung ist wertvoller als ein
aktueller test zählen ein aktueller pc
ist ja nur noch mal nahm franz klammer
unter jenige der jetzt also einen test
hat und falsch negativ ist also
infiziert ist dann auch sehr gefährlich
wenn er jemanden ansteckt derjenige der
trotz impfung positiv ist der ist nicht
so gefährlich wenn er nicht zu einem
lautsprecher werden gehören sie hängt zu
2g also wir haben eigentlich
gibt ja nur zwei möglichkeiten mit 2g
umzugehen entweder wir fangen jetzt
schon in den hochrisiko bereichen anders
einzusetzen um die inzidenz
herunterzudrücken oder wir machen es
später und dann ist der kreis sehr viel
größer war das problem geht ja nicht weg
sondern wird größer und daher wäre ich
eigentlich dafür dass wir in den
bereichen wo jetzt hohes risiko ist das
sogar schon soviel zweig praktizieren
wie geht denn wir haben bei den
ungeimpften haben wir derzeit unfassbar
hohe aber wirklich spektakulär hohe in
studenzen also die inzidenz sie
ausgewiesen wird ist also sozusagen die
incidents da tut man so als wenn ich für
die gesamte bevölkerung aber das sind ja
fast nur ungeimpfte das heißt in den
städten im ruhrgebiet oder auch in
leverkusen so da müssen wir davon
ausgehen dass beide in um bei den
umgeben ist die inzidenz irgendwo 500
oder 600 solche institution habe ja noch
gar nicht gab und das muss man daher
wäre ich auch dafür dass man die
gesondert ausweist das ist die residenz
für die geimpften und das ist die
inzidenz für die ungeimpften dann würden
wir auch sehr viel klarer kapieren und
sie machen das doch jetzt
ja dann kapiert man tatsächlich also wie
groß das risiko für die ungeimpften ist
und dann lässt sich für diese leute auch
zwei gsr rechtfertigen und dann ist
jetzt noch mal die frage so sind wir
eingestiegen in die sendung herr
lauterbach ob es ausnahmebedingungen und
ausnahmemöglichkeiten eben für die
genesenen und die geimpften gibt oder ob
sie am ende doch davon ausgehen dass es
für alle irgendwann kontakt
beschränkungen gibt da sagten sie am
anfang der sendung ja das können sie
sich vorstellen nee das glaube ich nicht
also wir werden tatsächlich bei den
ungeimpften also ich sage mal so
werden bei den ungeimpften viel mehr
machen müssen da wird zweig dann
wirklich also wenn die fallzahlen also
so hoch sind dass sagen wir alle wieder
betroffen sind die impfung wird ja
schwächer werden wir sehen in den
israelischen daten dass also die
impfungen also nach ein paar monaten an
also sagen wir schutzfaktor also
verlieren
das
wären besser aber wenn das sagen wir die
geimpften auch gefährdet sind werden wir
bei den ungeimpften sehr viel mehr
machen müssen um zu verhindern dass wir
locker uns brauchen wie christian
drosten sie eben am anfang der sendung
in dem einspieler gezeigt dass wir das
nichtvergessen worüber wir schon fachen
frau allmendinger geben müssen auf die
schulen und auf die familien gucken
deshalb da gibt es nicht deshalb geht
auch zweig nicht jetzt einfach so
kommt geografisch von rechtsaußen und
ist eine völlig richtige argument jetzt
haben sich die renten rechtsaußen
jetzt haben sich die
gesundheitsminister und die
schulminister bildungsminister darauf
verständigt keine quarantäne mehr
gesundheitsminister allen voran keine
quarantäne mehr über 14 tage nach fünf
tagen kann man sich frei testen es muss
nicht mehr die ganze klasse in
quarantäne aber ist es jetzt schon der
große befreiungsschlag für die familie
in gar keiner weise auch sonst ist es ja
immer noch sehr unterschiedlich die
gesundheitsämter haben das letzte wort
auch die frage wer sitzt eigentlich
neben leben ist sehr merkwürdig weil es
immer mehr gemeinsame projekte gibt es
ja nicht so wie in meiner schulzeit dass
er jemanden der gleichen person saß wäre
das vielleicht noch gegangen und was wir
sehen und wir überprüfen das er sehr
genau auch mit unseren daten ist dass
frauen oder väter die schlichtweg nicht
zur arbeit gehen können weil die kinder
so oft in quarantäne sind und immer
wieder in quarantäne sind dass das eine
das darunter die erwerbstätigkeit was
die fly.de die psychischen störungen zu
nehmen das andere und mindestens genauso
wichtig ist dass die kinder einfach ich
würde schon fast sagen gleich zu chancen
bekommen also ich weiß am wochenende
viel mit kleinkindern unterwegs die sich
gar nicht mehr trauen mit erwachsenen in
geschlossenen räume zu gehen ich rede
jetzt gar nicht über andere fragen wie
gewichts gewinnen und die frage der der
selbstwirksamkeit oder
die lehrer und rückstände und es ist ein
ganz bitterer befund mit diesem
präsenzunterricht für den sie sehr
plädieren viele menschen plädieren dafür
dass die kinder endlich wieder in die
schule können geht man natürlich kluge
in das risiko einer durchseuchung
ist das in ihrer abwägung schon zu einem
ergebnis gekommen ja ich denke wir
müssen alles tun damit die schulen offen
bleiben die schäden gerade für die
kinder sind wirklich immens durch die
pandemie und deswegen dürfen bald nicht
aufhören zu testen und auch abstand und
maske in gewissen situationen schulen
und damit muss einfach erreicht werden
dass die schulen offen bleiben und man
eine schnelle durchseuchung in diesen
altersgruppen befindet eine schnelle
durchseuchung verhindern die müssen wir
verhindern würden sie sagen herr hologic
dass die empfehlung der stiko für die
zwölf- bis 17-jährigen dazu spät kam
auch eine impfung für die jungen leute
zu
empfehlung auszusprechen ich hätte sie
mir früher gewünscht ja
ja und
insofern kommt dass jetzt wieder ein
bisschen spät um den kindern und eltern
dann vor der schule die
impfung noch zu ermöglichen genau das
heißt auch wir sind ja daran im moment
diese info angebote jetzt zu machen an
den schulen und haben es jetzt auch in
den ferien über die luft zentren und
andere bereiche gemacht das ziel auch
der gesundheitsminister der minister ist
ganz klar präsenzunterricht und das
wollen wir mit allen mitteln auch
durchsetzen deswegen quarantäne
verkürzungen engmaschige testsysteme in
bayern in grund- und förderschulen zb
pool tests darüber hinaus an die gen
schnelltests des kölner zusammen ein
engmaschiges testsystem hygieneregeln
maske und natürlich das impfen und
natürlich alle die um die kinder herum
sind massiv in die jugendlichen weil die
bringen ja das mit rein
und dann sind wir aber trotzdem bei der
gleichen frage auch noch mal in ihre
richtung da ist die richtige kamera
man riskiert eine durchseuchung mit den
präsenzunterricht weil man die jüngsten
kinder natürlich noch nicht das nicht
impfen kann und sie haben das war zu
lesen auch entschieden dass sie ihre
kinder beispielsweise auch gar nicht
impfen wollen
müsste man nicht schon zur sicherheit
der kinder
dafür sorgen dass eben wirklich viel
mehr erwachsene sich impfen lassen
eindeutig ja die erwachsenen sollten
diesen schutz für die kinder jetzt
bereitstellen dem sie sich impfen lassen
das ist auch eine verantwortung der man
nachkommen sollte meine kinder sehen wir
uns alle unter 12 und daher war die
frage einer zeitung ob ich die impfen
lassen will ich so richtig los ja
natürlich ist ja ich sag nein will ich
nicht weil ich habe aber auch den grund
dazu genannt sind unter 12 und je jünger
die kinder sind umso geringer ist eben
das risiko der infektion und deswegen
als der nutzen der impfung wie ihr
kleiner die kinder sind immer geringer
selbst verstehen haben meine kinder auch
die sechsfach impfung alle also die
kinderkrankheiten wer geimpft ich bin
kein imker vielleicht um das auch noch
mal deutlich zu machen ich würde aber
auch hier noch mal dafür plädieren
korrekte risiko abwägung vorzunehmen
auf der einen seite haben wir das risiko
der infektion ist je älter man ist umso
größer und je jünger man ist umso
geringer was da droht ein
krankenhausaufenthalt oder gar tot und
auf der anderen seite haben wir halt das
risiko dass schäden von
schulschließungen und da wissen wir
darüber tragen noch mehr zu sagen können
dass die so gravierend sind dass wir
weitere schulschließungen einfach gar
nicht in erwägung ziehen dürfen sondern
wir müssen alles tun dass die kinder
möglichst wenig infiziert werden aber
das restrisiko das bleibt die meisten
kinder hassen symptomlos in der
infektion des restrisiko das bleibt muss
man in kauf nehmen weil ansonsten das
nächste schuljahr wieder so abläufe das
nächste das letzte die schäden für die
kinder einfach größer sind als das was
durch die des virus zu befürchten ist
und wir haben im februar schon
angefangen mit den regelmäßigen tests
das wird in deutschland mittlerweile
überall gemacht wir haben auch
einzubringen jetzt wieder gesagt alle
ungeimpften erzieherinnen werden täglich
getestet als erstes ziehen wir durch das
geht 80 prozent unserer beschäftigten
sind auch geimpft konnten wir erheben
das ging alles und ich glaube mit diesem
vorsichtsmaßnahme natürlich sind auch
alle schulen komplett jetzt mit dem 22
gestattet damit das lüften besser
funktioniert gesteuerter funktioniert
wie diesen vorsichtsmaßnahmen finde ich
muss es dann auch ausreichend wir können
es uns nicht leisten wieder in die
bildungs- und die entwicklungs verläufe
so einzugreifen die im letzten jahr
wegen des restrisikos das dann halt
bleibt das ist keine durchseuchung
sondern restrisiko und das müssen wir
meiner meinung nach würde interessant
100 kinder in kauf nehmen lauterbach
wird schon ein bisschen unruhig wir
fragen ihn gleich weil er vor den
schweren verläufen die auch kinder haben
kann natürlich seit geraumer zeit warnt
frage zunächst an den mediziner wieviel
long beach fälle hatten sie schon auf
der station haben sie sie überhaupt
schon da
naja bei denen patienten der sieg
wichtig waren haben wir natürlich häufig
sowieso folgeschäden und die müssen
monatelang und jugendliche bin kein
kinderarzt aber die kinder ärzte sagen
mir dass longo wird bei kindern wirklich
doch deutlich seltener vorkommt als das
initial gedacht haben also bei kindern
scheint das nicht so eine rolle zu
spielen bei erwachsenen da hat man
natürlich schon einzelfälle die schwer
betroffen sind 1 prozent
hospitalisierung sagt man bei kindern
herr lauterbach sie sagen dass es
schwere verläufe gibt und warnen davor
wenn man so eine schule zumacht dann
macht man es allen kindern schwer genau
was ich werde gleich einen vorschlag
machen wie man machen wie man vorgehen
könnte aber bei longo wird also habe in
dieser woche an der petition entgegen
genommen und unterschriften 51.000
lankowitz also patienten hatten
unterschrieben man schätzt wir haben in
deutschland 400.000 wir machen viel zu
wenig für longo wird betroffen
bei den kindern das ist gott sei dank
ist das statistische risiko dass kinder
schwer kranken oder lang fit bekommen
nicht so groß aber wenn es einer
durchseuchung gäbe dann wäre es
natürlich viele fälle es ist ganz klar
also dass
das gesetz der großen zahl und diese
gefahr besteht ja nicht jetzt sondern
besteht in ein paar monaten wenn wir
nicht mehr so gut lüften können wenn die
kinder auch erkältungskrankheiten haben
wenn die schulen dann quasi geparkt sind
dann wurden wir wenn wir nichts also
dagegen unternehmen hätten wir eine
rasche durch forschung dafür ist diese
beta variante einfach viel zu ansteckend
und also wie man es aus meiner sicht
machen wir dass man mit einer kurz
container arbeitet wenn in einer klasse
ein fall vor kommt lasst nur das kind
welches auto betroffen ist zu hause
bleibt und das an in den folgenden fünf
tagen die anderen kinder in der klasse
alle jeden morgen zum beispiel mit einem
schnelltest getestet werden mathematisch
kann man dann zeigen dass man eine
weitere ausbreitung in der klasse oder
in der schule dann unterbinden kann weil
ich dann durch das tägliche testen
sofort raus wenn du morgens sei es noch
ein anderes kind was ich infiziert hat
eltern die das nicht mitmachen wollen wo
die eltern gezeigt und ich wollen dass
das kind getestet wird die müssen leute
kinder lauterbach das haben wir mehrfach
dieses dieses jahr in der dritten welle
genau so praktiziert vor die zustimmung
des funktioniert absolut und das
funktioniert absolut und dann ist das
eine alternative dazu frau allmendinger
den kindern wieder diesen wahnsinn diese
psychotische zustände zuzumuten und den
eltern auch na ja wir könnten ja noch
viel mehr tun also wenn ich vergleiche
was wir in schulen tun im vergleich zu
dem was wird über die letzten semester
im hochschulbereich getan haben war das
im hochschulbereich deutlich mehr muss
ich mal sagen wir haben große hotels
angemietet dass die abschlussprüfungen
praktiziert werden konnten wir haben
aber bei den schulen nicht die anlieger
in hotels oder museen mit großen flächen
angemietet wir haben auch nicht unsere
studierenden die sehr gut auch gerade
bei diesem dann digital unterstützten
unterricht allerdings im klassen kontext
oder zu hause wenn sie in quarantäne war
in irgendeiner weise genutzt das heißt
wir brauchen doch hier auch soziale
innovationen die wir da und her die uns
denken und müssen nicht immer an dem
schulklassen
quadratmeterzahlen da hängen und dem
lehrer sterben sondern wir können diese
ja wirklich schwierige zeit und für
kinder auch in der zukünftigen
entwicklung massiv beeinflussen denn
seither mit neuen
maßnahmen wird begleiten aerologic sie
würden auch sagen das ist jetzt ein fakt
dass man tatsächlich mit einer impfung
die kinder und jugendlichen schützen
würde ab 12 oder werden diese impfungen
ab 12 empfohlen um eigentlich unsere
impfquote nach oben zu treiben die stiko
hat sich ja jetzt klar für diese
impfungen ausgesprochen wir wissen ja
dass das eine risikoabwägung war die
getroffen wurde im verhältnis und
insofern ist die frage klar beantwortet
die stiko empfiehlt auch den 12 bis 17
jährigen diese impfung als
schutzfaktoren das ist glaube ich das
entscheidende
und ich kann nur noch mal sagen das
entscheidende für uns auch politisch ist
wirklich präsenzunterricht sagen weil
ich ihnen völlig zustimme kinder und
jugendliche haben wirklich gelitten und
das ist eine große herausforderung auch
für die zukunft ich bin ja auch wirklich
der meinung wir müssen aus der panini
irgendwann mal lehren ziehen eine wird
auch sein und das haben wir auch
eingefordert dass man eine
enquetekommission mal macht und bewertet
was denn das für kinder und jugendliche
heißt und was wir da in zukunft besser
machen können das ist tatsächlich ein
ganz zentrales und wichtiges thema der
pause keine enquete-kommission die daten
liegen meilenweit vor und zwar in jeder
hinsicht so und wir sind dann noch bei
der frage nach der booster impfung das
ist jetzt auch was es was die menschen
sehr bewegt und auch unsicher macht wie
viele impfungen kann ein mensch
eigentlich körperlich vertragen
das ist kein problem auch gegen
influenza gegen grippe werden wir ja ja
ich hab mir jetzt darauf hoffen den
booster impfung also wenn wir jetzt
tatsächlich risikogruppen und die
älteren nach sechs monaten auf frischen
dann ist das erstens kein problem
sondern wirklich gut und zweitens auch
noch mit der grippe zusätzlich auch das
ist möglich genau wobei wir natürlich
von der stiko nochmal genau wissen
müssen für wen jetzt diese booster
impfung empfohlen wird es wird aber
darauf hinauslaufen dass das im mond
reformierte sind zum beispiel
transplantierte patienten patienten das
immunsystem nicht so funktioniert und
die hochbetagten das wird wahrscheinlich
kommen und auch da nicken die
gesundheitsministerien check und wir
hätten schon mal genug impfstoff für
diese puste kommen ja wir haben das auch
noch einmal klipp und klar gesagt das
ist ein thema der gesundheitlichen
vorsorge
deswegen sind wir der meinung ist es
wichtig jetzt in die alten und
pflegeheime wieder zu gehen damit wir
eben nicht die situation erleben die wir
schon mal hatten und dass wir da
wirklich jetzt gezielt auch diese
impfungen machen die sind von der
zulassung auch gedeckt und darauf würde
ich mir natürlich auch wünschen dass wir
bald mal eine stiko empfehlung kriegen
ja das wäre ich denke der immer global
also ich meine für die pflegeheime der
stimmlich hinzu als nicht ärzte aber die
frage ob wir dann diese booster impfung
für personenkreise die sie gar nicht
brauchen gegebenenfalls für deutschland
benutzen nicht sehr viel mehr global sie
einsetzen die fanden impfstoffe das ist
für mich eine ganz ganz große frage und
herr lauterbach holt jetzt tief luft und
wir reden nicht über die große ganze
welt das haben wir hier in dieser
sendung schon viel getan sondern noch
einmal über olaf scholz den
kanzlerkandidaten der spd der ja
tatsächlich sagte wir waren alle die
versuchskaninchen für diejenigen die
bisher abgewartet haben und ich als
einer von den 50 millionen sie kennen
den text war es so schlau dass olaf
scholz ausgerechnet so ein reizwort und
träger wird der impfgegner und
querdenker der benutzten das war doch
ein witz hat versucht also hat ein
scherz gemacht und es wird ja aber das
war ein witz in dem sinne oder shorts
hat bei anderer gelegenheit korrekter
weise immer darauf hingewiesen wie gut
die impfstoffe untersucht gewesen sind
als wir die genutzt haben wir haben sie
ja dann noch also auf der grundlage
empfohlen das wichtige empfehlungen gab
sie uns weiter so mit dass man das war
vielleicht also an etwas missglückter
witz aber dass ich gegen jemanden zu
verwenden also und so zu tun als wenn er
aus wenn das eine ernste aussage gewesen
wäre das nicht richtig trotz dem einsatz
zum bus dann auch sagen will ich da es
ist tatsächlich so dass wir da in einen
harten konflikt kommen die also kovacs
initiative die beispielsweise die
menschen in afrika impfen soll wir haben
jetzt schon 25 prozent weniger also
impfstoff als zugesagt dort einsetzen
können weil booster impfungen verwendet
werden das heißt wir müssen uns ganz
genau überlegen wer braucht die bewusste
impfung wir können es uns nicht leisten
aus moralischen gründen die booster
impfung an ihr auf vorrat zu verwenden
und kommen und sie haben sogar weiter zu
enthalten dass also das macht sich jetzt
schon also in afrika bemerkt dass jetzt
die booster impfungen beginnen und für
die unternehmen ist es natürlich
attraktiver war der gleiche impfstoff
ist bei uns teurer verkauft also für den
afrikaner immer wichtiger